all right let's look at some of your
feedback from the last week Friday
feedback featuring emails YouTube
comments Twitter replies subreddit posts
and all sorts of other ways that people
communicate with us you can always email
info davidpackman.com but your posts and
commentary on any of our platforms might
be selected we'll start with some
criticisms these are not exactly the
most classy criticisms John wrote in and
said do Alvin Bragg and David packman
watch three or four hours of porn every
day of their miserable lives get woke go
broke let's go Brandon now many of you
would say David there's nothing here to
actually address you're not you're not
right though get woke go broke as Farren
cousins so beautifully explained last
week this idea that quote getting woke
makes you go broke really doesn't seem
to be accurate and in fact we looked at
some very interesting polling data down
from Florida data which shows that
despite the concerted effort and attack
campaign by Ron Des Sanctus and other
Republicans against wokeness most
Floridians and most Americans actually
agree with the fundamental underlying
reality of wokeness which is I'm aware
of problems in society and that it would
be great to fix them and this sort of
thing so that it actually does seem that
wokeness is winning I address that in a
segment a few weeks ago as well as far
as the other stuff let's go Brandon and
Alvin Bragg's uh uh habits or whatever I
I don't know maybe go ask someone who
cares about that stuff next email is
from Mauricio who wrote in about
progressives and Firearms this is a very
interesting email says hey David I'm a
U.S Air Force veteran with experience
with a variety of firearms I own a few
guns mainly for recreational purposes
although there is a self-defense element
I consider myself a progressive although
I try to be rational and like to hear
other perspectives to get to the root of
issues there are a few things I'm
interested in your perspective on what
is your perception of progressive gun
owners is this something you would
encourage discourage or are neutral
about is there any message you have for
Liberal gun owners well I have many
liberal gun owning friends I as I've
said before on the show I I don't really
talk about my ownership or lack thereof
of firearms I just I just don't I don't
see any reason to necessarily talk about
it I've opted not to mention whether I
do or don't own firearms but one of the
things I have said before
is I would like the entire situation
around Firearms to be different it
should be much more expensive training
and Licensing should be much more
extensive you should be required to have
insurance if you have firearms there
should be limits on more limits on what
Firearms people can buy and in
particular people under age 25 I've
given all that list and if I were a
firearm owner myself I would be more
than willing to subject myself to all of
those requirements as well I would
prefer
there be way fewer guns in circulation
and dramatically so
given the status quo today
I don't love the idea
of the right Wingers being the only ones
with the Firearms like that doesn't
sound good either and it's not about
government tyranny because I think that
that's quite a silly argument but it's
if you zoom out and you say there's 400
million firearms in this country do I
want
370 million of them in the hands of
right Wingers including a lot of
right-wing nuts no that doesn't sound
particularly good so I get that this is
sort of like a race to the bottom type
thing well so if the Liberals get the
guns then I get it believe me I get it
given where things are
I don't want the right Wingers to be the
only ones with the guns call me crazy
next email is from James writing about
2024 and says given both bidens and
Trump's Ages come the next election
there's a real possibility that either
one or both could have to pull out due
to ill health or Worse pass away last
minute what chaos do you feel could
follow thanks Jim from Ireland yeah
listen statistically speaking it is more
likely that people in their late 70s or
early 80s will die than someone who's 45
statistically that is absolutely the
case whether this is likely you know we
we looked at Actuarial tables uh looking
at Joe Biden and Donald Trump's ages and
it is still
it is still more likely than not that
they will survive to the next election
but there is no doubt that if either if
either is or both were the nominees and
if either were to die close to the time
of the election or even imagine between
the election and the inauguration it
would be chaotic and this is less about
the law and more about I mean listen if
Trump's winning by four
and November 1st 2024 he dies and
Republicans scramble and they put in I
don't know who hard to imagine a
scenario where I don't know who actually
wins same thing would apply to Joe Biden
so I think that that would be the most
likely outcome that if uh one of the
candidates if a nominee were to die at a
very late stage of the campaign
um it's unlikely that whoever replaces
them is going to win that that I think
is the most likely outcome the myth
wrote in and said sorry to hear that you
don't have a channel anymore about the
YouTube channel I also heard about this
from John who says is it true you got
kicked off YouTube no so several weeks
ago now we did an April Fool's joke
saying the right-wing mob won and I lost
my YouTube channel now the truth is you
can't really lose your YouTube channel
or get kicked off you could get banned
from YouTube for publishing content
repeatedly that's in violation of
YouTube's terms and conditions but it's
an important thing to remember that they
can't really take your YouTube channel
from you or shut it down and I am really
thrilled to be able to say that actually
the channel had its best month in a
really long time in March April is
looking incredible you know what not
long ago
I had the goal of saying I want to
steadily get a million views a day on
YouTube steadily not just like oh here's
a good day we got a million but we're
averaging way fewer
we've recently been averaging close to
1.5 million views per day on the YouTube
channel which is stunning and I have
only you to think so fortunately the
YouTube channel is alive and well let's
look at a YouTube comment this one's
from thar CX4 UK uq
who says about the North Carolina
elected official who switched party from
democratic to Republican as a politician
you shouldn't be allowed to switch
parties midterm you should only be
allowed to do it when running for
re-election that way the voters know who
they are voting for it's an interesting
idea understand that you would of course
have to announce that
you could be a Democrat
if you announce that you're running for
re-election a year before the election
you would be announcing then I'm running
as a republican so you're still sort of
making it known just as early and you
could still vote however you wanted so
while it's an interesting idea from thar
I don't know that in Practical terms it
really solves the issue that I think
they're getting at
feedback about last week's guest hosts
the good news as I mentioned on the
bonus show on Monday is that almost
everybody who wrote in about last week's
guest hosts which included producer Pat
Luke Beasley and farron cousins almost
everybody who wrote in said I I liked at
least one of them and that's a really
great thing Michael says Pat and Luke
did the best jobs of handling the show
hands down pat being the better of the
two but both were more true to your
demeanor I would much rather see these
two guest hosts alternate alternate days
assuming it's difficult to prepare daily
so that's Michael
um Stephen wrote in and said providing
feedback that I much prefer Luke as a
host the reason for this is that I watch
your show for political commentary with
a progressive touch Faron cousins comes
off as a left-wing preacher and it's
very off-putting his Vibe just doesn't
match the show you or Pat with two T's
so a lot going on spelling wise but a
very interesting bit of feedback and
then other people wrote in and said
farron's the only one that I watched
other people wrote it and said you know
the problem with farron and Luke is they
have their own channel so then I end up
seeing they cover the stories and then
they cover them for you and it doesn't
make sense but the whole idea was
something for everyone
and I would call it an unmitigated
success but we'll keep trying different
formulations in the future lastly a post
from reflex point on the subreddit who
says I was impressed with Gavin Newsom I
get the feeling he's gearing up to be in
line for a 2028 run or even 2024 if
something were to happen to Biden before
the election I think this interview he
had with Brian Tyler Cohen was very good
and worth watching he has a fighting
spirit that I think Dems need and he's
not afraid to take the fight to the
right and put him on the defensive even
if it's not him we need someone that is
not afraid to be confrontational with
Republicans Brian Tyler Cohen's
interview with Gavin Newsom was
excellent I recommend you check that out
and I tend to agree and as I've said
before I don't think Gavin Newsom is the
be-all end-all of the progressive
politician of the future I think he has
policy areas where I agree policy areas
where he's sort of like okay
but the critical thing about Newsome is
he is willing to be ruthless in the way
that the left should be ruthless when it
comes to these Republicans that's a very
good thing not everybody's willing to do
it so I think Newsome is a very
interesting guy although I don't think
he is the Uber Progressive
um but there are many considerations
when we think about who would make a
good nominee how they would handle
attacks from Republicans is an important
part of that how what would their
demeanor be in debates important part of
that all of those things very very
interesting candidate potential
candidate he's not he hasn't announced
that he's running uh send me your
thoughts info davidpackman.com
post to the subreddit or leave a comment
on YouTube or whatever the case may be
please remember
to ensure that you were subscribed to
the YouTube channel hit that subscribe
button we are pushing our way slowly to
2 million subscribers and also remember
that much of our content is available in
Spanish at davidpackman.com Spanish if
you know anyone who would like or
benefit from this content but would
better consume it in Spanish rather than
English let them know about
davidpackman.com Spanish we will see you
on the bonus show in mere moments